uh can you tell us how have the last few
days been
emotionally and how do you feel now
about sort of the result of the work put
in
the the accord with the players coaches
in the league
uh the results of all the work that you
guys have done these last few days
uh i mean i think it's it's great i
think we all needed a pause
um i think emotionally
physically mentally and i think that
the pause was for a greater cause not
just for basketball but
for all the social issues in our world
today
and obviously based on
recent events across the world and
recent
police killings and shooting um it
allowed us
to use our platform to be able to stop
what we're doing
and recognize how important
the rest of the world and me being a
black man in our
african-american communities how
important it is to be able to
pause and understand how us as a league
us as owners collectively how can we
come together and make sure that we're
doing the right thing
as it pertains to that how does it feel
to know that the platform that you have
is effective that it's powerful
it works um you know number one it's a
blessing i think
a lot of people don't understand how
strong and how powerful
it is uh we're on tv every day um our
faces are
you know some of the most well-known
people in the world when people see us
and
kids look up to us and to me it's an
unbelievable blessing and i believe that
at least for me personally god has put
me in this position
for a reason to be able to not just to
play basketball but to use my platform
to better help other people
and help our youth help people across
the globe and understand how important
uh different things in life life is
thank you christy rican
hey russ i know you have some um young
children like jacob blake
did or does and i was wondering how
difficult was
was it for you to see what happened to
him happen in front of his children
and how much do you hope what y'all are
doing can be able to affect
real change in this country man you know
honestly
i watch the video um and
it's heartbreaking you know it's it's
something that is
you can't explain and it's something
that is
just not right um been maybe growing up
in the university of los angeles and
been able to see
the different uh police brutality that
happened and on everyday life
and for me to be able to see that number
one is heartbreaking and
in my mind
i wanted to find a way to help and make
change and
and the good thing about our league and
our players we all felt the same way
about the situation and for us to be
able to take a pause and
break to be able to now come to a few
things that we think is
important for now and and obviously
there's so many other things going on in
our society that we can we can tackle
but
i think initially tackling our voting
and finding ways to be able to use our
teams and our arenas to be able to
understand why voting is important and i
think that's a trickle-down effect
to our police reform
uh as you would say our final ways to be
able to
make sure our cops and the cops around
the world
number one get penalized and their
consequences for their actions
especially when they're um
you know unjust haley griffin
kaylee
we'll go with tim mcmahon
russ i appreciate what you guys are
doing with uh with social justice but
i want to change subjects real quick and
ask you about your health how are you
feeling physically with the quad
and uh mike says he thinks he'll be some
sort of minutes restriction on you
tomorrow
uh what are your thoughts on that i'm
taking day by day
um that's all i can do um just taking
them one day at a time and
that's what i've been doing that's all i
got for you
mark berman
russ along those lines how excited are
you to get back out there
in game five um
you know i'm i'm excited to play but i'm
also i'm more excited
that we're playing uh for a cause
playing that we're in agreeance to to be
able to
make sure that's action like uh for for
guys like myself and i'm pretty sure
guys around the league is
you know we play and we have our names
on the back of our jerseys and we have
our messaging on the back of our jerseys
and that means something and it's not
just something that we just put on there
for fun or for kicks and giggles but it
actually
means something is actually something
that uh
i personally take action and take
responsive possibility in being
an african-american athlete um a black
man in this society
um having a son of my my own and having
other kids that look up to me from my
neighborhood around the world
is something that that's that's what i'm
most excited about moving forward
and obviously basketball is our platform
is something that i love and embrace
to do but to me that is the most
important
reason why we're actually even coming
back to play
because if there wasn't any agreements
or there's no action moving towards
some of the things that we we talked
about as players and me personally i
wouldn't be playing
ryan bearfield
well russ when you see things like the
jacob lake
incident how how does that make you feel
knowing that you have a teammate and
somebody you know personally in table
cephalosia who has went through
police brutality you know what it hits
home
for many reasons man i i grew up in
south central los angeles
i've been around people my friends i
have family and friends that
been subject to police brutality i have
people that i know friends that are cops
as well um
so i've been privy to to to it all men
and
since i was young and my parents has
always taught me to find ways to be able
to use your platform to be able to
not not one help your community but
actually be involved and be
up front and where you you are actually
in the field and finding ways to be able
to help
that community and
this year has been crazy we have the
election coming up
this is a pandemic going on where people
are losing their lives and
families are struggling um it's
it's so much going on at one time man i
think it's
a time where we actually take a break
and actually think about
the things we need to do and do them
it's a lot of talking
and everybody likes to talk about what
they want to do and how they want to do
it but
it's another step to actually doing it
and that's what i'm all about
his action and making sure that that
that
is happening right away
dan wilkie
hey russ um you kind of touched this but
how
how close do you think was this season
to ending
um on wednesday night thursday and then
secondly ownership around this league
has committed money in the past but
there are people that don't necessarily
agree with you politically
and stuff like that how do you how heard
you feel
by people who may not be on the same
side on some of
some of these issues i know we've heard
because once the nba stop
everything else stopped and to me that
shows a lot that shows
the platform that shows the power of us
as players and uh
our voices were heard and i don't know
how close we were to stopping and
if that was an opportunity but i do know
one thing we stopped for a reason
we needed a pause we needed a break and
i think it's very very important that we
not just
you know the owners tell us that what
they're going to do and how we're going
to do them together but we hold them
accountable
and i think that's another step of
making sure that things that we
discussed
amongst each other in this partnership
that get done
and they get done in the fashion where
we both can agree on and
we show we see the impact we see the
change that's happening
across our world michael shapiro
hi russell uh i just wanted to know if
you could detail at all your
conversation with michael jordan
and how we kind of help the players and
the owners kind of get on a path to
some social justice initiatives you know
mj has
always been huge and
finding ways to give back to not just
communities but the african-american
community and me being with jordan
brandon
and him being on the side of ownership
and being
a black owner is huge and during
the meeting and doing the conversation
between
myself the players and owners he was
huge and huge and
and making sure that whatever it is that
we wanted to do together
we make sure we get it done and i think
that's the next step as i mentioned
before is
we've had previous conversations with
with ownership
and and players and some of the things
that we wanted weren't able to get done
but i think
mj was real adamant about making sure
that you know we
we get things done and get them done the
right way
we'll take two more craig bailey
hey russ how much of a sense inside the
the bubble with with your teammates and
other players in the nba is there that
five years from now 20 years from now
you can look back
at this and say that you were part of
meaningful change
and and meaningful change in the way
that people of color
are treated in this country um i can't
speak for anybody else i speak
how they feel for me personally um it's
something that i
i think about daily um and even before
i came into bubble since i've been in
the nba and since i've
grown up in in the city of los angeles
and finding ways to
to give back i've always
thought about legacy and figuring out a
way to be
able to what does it mean what does your
legacy mean is it just about basketball
and i
i don't think mine is about basketball i
believe mine is about
giving back and not just giving back but
impacting
and inspiring and finding ways to be
able to
do what's right and today's day in
society
our black communities has been hurting
for many many many years
and i feel like i have the platform i
have the ability to be able to reach
certain people and i feel like it's my
duty to make sure that
our black people are hurt our black man
or her
our communities underserved communities
are heard and
i'm gonna do everything in my power to
make sure that happens and
to be involved with something like this
today
i'll be you know i'll be lying here
saying if i wasn't
putting that on the line first and
making sure that i'm a part of of
history
um in a positive way and making sure
that and whether it's five years 10
years 20 years down the line
that i can look back and say i was a
part of that and i put my best foot
forward
last one karen terrace
hey ross how's it going hey i want to
ask you i mean
how long i mean where you all have you
always felt empowered
in terms of being able to express
yourself and i mean
if and if not i mean what at what point
did that kind of come
come to life that you know you have this
power and this ability to to
to make people listen um i always felt
like this i may have no way
i always spoken out to you guys about it
but i'm more about action
um i do a lot of things on a daily and
day out basis
um in a community that i don't publicize
nor do i
bring cameras i'm more about impacting
our people and they see my face they
understand
that i'm serious about helping and
inspiring
people um and today's day where there's
social media
you're able to see things that people do
what they say and i'm more about action
and i've always been outspoken as
pertains to
my beliefs on the underserved community
on the black communities
because that's where i grew up because i
can say i was one of those kids i was
i was those kids in the back community i
didn't have access to
different educational programs different
things to educate ourselves about
politics educate ourselves about
african-american history
and um i want to be the person that a
kid that
that was my age or you know a young
teenager can say you know
russell westbrook came back and it's
because of him that i i understand and i
know
um about our history i understand what
it's like to understand
the wrongs and rights and i want to be
consistently stand on point to to our
communities and it's something that i've
always believed in and something i'm
going to continue to do
thank you russell yeah appreciate it
russell westbrook talking about he's
about action and
impacting for his people will he appear
in game five
you'll have to stick around and see we
have